nome anita vitale età 25 21 quasi 32
segno zodiacale ariete ascendente
sagittario bilancia di dove sei
sono sarda perfettamente sono pugliese
della provincia di lecce ha decisamente
di marittima un paesino di muscolo
come vi siete conosciuti ci siamo
conosciuti a lavoro in ufficio
ci siamo conosciuti negli uffici di
houghton hardcore
qual è la prima cosa che hai pensato
quando l'hai visto ho pensato che mi
sembra un ragazzo serio e responsabile
con i team per terra insomma ho pensato
alla ragazza così giovane e molto molto
molto intelligente 3 tuoi pregi
altruista creativa e cile dire imprese
che siano infastidire i difetti di cuore
ti reputo credo di essere divertente al
turista è sempre aperto al dialogo e 3
tuoi difetti si sentì bile emotiva e
troppo sensibile tra quei difetti alla
tenda dimenticare tutto sono insicuro e
spesso parlo troppo quando mi piace
3 pregi dall'altro persona è vitale
molto generoso molto altruista e
simpatico vita una persona molto
sensibile intelligenza e e ha sempre
tanta tanta fantasia tre difetti dall
altra persona mangia troppo è un po è
sicuro e si dimentica troppo alcol
testarda spesso molto diffidente è una
grande ormai ora il tuo colore preferito
allora mi piace molto e celeste il rosa
pronta cappello rosso mio colore
preferito i blues sono anche molto i
colori chiari il bianco iva 12 chiaro il
tuo animale preferito a tutti gli
animali mi piacciono tantissimo gli
animali miei preferiti sono il piatto il
cavallo le caprette e i pappagalli mio
animale preferito è sicuramente il gatto
se vincessi alla lotteria un milione
cosa compreresti innanzitutto un pre in
casa per di per tre tranquilla poi fare
tanti regali e alla mia famiglia poi
donerei tanto in beneficenza soprattutto
per associazioni che
gli animali abbandonati comprerei un
bellerio per poter viaggiare libertà e
poi venti macchine fotografiche computer
mi piace troppo
mi piace troppo smontare aiuti over
spesso dopo lo riesco rimonta prima un
viaggio che vorresti fare
mi piacerebbe tanto tornare in
california soprattutto a san francisco
ma vi che sarebbe tanto anche visitare
in giappone tokyo mi piacerebbe molto
che si dare alla fiat e non solo la
thailandia ma anche il giappone prossimo
viaggio probabilmente mi piacerebbe
visitare giappone è un viaggio in italia
invece unificato un bel po del sud
dell'italia quindi anche se rivendicare
in nord italia milano e normalista mi
piacerebbe vedere il lato di carta è
fatta a verona nel nord e quindi
immancabile vedere
mi piacerebbe visitare la sicilia ma
anche il nord italia che animò la
vorresti aubert il mio sogno è avere
tantissimi animali salvati dalla strada
e ho adottato insomma è per ora mi
piacerebbe avere un gatto
tantissimo anche avere un pappagallo e
non so se sia possibile avere entrambi
vorrei avere dei gatti ea loro dei cani
è una coperta per far contenta re in
terrore permettere cibo preferito allora
ovviamente la fitta mi piace molto la
pizza vegetariana con le verdure sopra
ma mi piace tantissimo anche di studi
cimenta italiano perché fondato il caldo
il mio cibo preferito è sicuramente la
pasta tutti i tipi di pasta diciamo la
pizza ovviamente con alcune faranno
della pizza chi può farlo è un cibo che
disgusta
insomma sicuramente carne e pesce in
generale perché non li mando da
tantissimi tantissimi amici molluschi
rivi cantante preferito me ne piazzano
tanti ma in questo periodo ex irab
cantante preferito brasil santella
gruppo della rumena quindi chiosato di
harry potter
allora ho fatto vari quiz e ognuno mi ha
dato una risposta diversa comunque le
risposte che ho avuto sono state che
sono in grifondoro però leggendo le
descrizioni delle varie cause mimì vedo
mi rispecchia di più nella descrizione
della
stata corvonero tassorosso chi è più
bravo nei video io anche se la sta
cavando molto bene ultimamente
beh sicuramente anita più brava nei
video è molto più che ostiglia reagire
di ma chi è più bravo fare slime io
neanche domande un'inter che bravo a
fare gli slide chi è più bravo a usare
la videocamera noi camera credo io
conosco da conosco più i dettagli del
delle camere mani oppure se la cava
molto tel
chi mangia di più lui decisamente
certamente il romanzo di più che scuola
iv lato il liceo in cui ho frequentato
la sua carriera di san giuseppe
tornando indietro e la cambieresti per
caso
in realtà quando stavo scegliendo la
scuola pensavo di fare l'artistico
perché volevo imparare ad andare il
computer per fare grafica e una sezione
a puntata artistico che ti insegna a
questo e volevo anche imparare a
disegnare bene
per ora la cambierei perché penso credi
in questo super importanti da imparare
da una parte insomma assolutamente no è
stata un'esperienza bellissima e la
fantastica mi ha dato la possibilità di
trovare lavoro sin da subito che
richiede tanto impegno e voglia di
lavorare e studiare e quante lingue
parli italiano inglese un po di spagnolo
e sardo ma ripeto è una lingua no in
realtà non lo parlo bene l'italiano
il dialetto l'inglese un pochettino di
francese e tolle leggermente imparando
lo spagnolo quindi quattro e mezzo
diciamo da chi è più bravo in inglese
io decisamente allora in inglese come
pronuncia che prova la vita con un
vocabolario credo di aver più puro capo
lari la tua serie tv preferita non
riesco a scegliere tra il trono di spade
breaking bad e stringenti le amo
tantissimo
tutte e tre con un grande appassionato
di serie tv ma grazie ad anita ho potuto
ho potuto vederne qualcuna ed al momento
serie tv che preferisco breaking bad
qual è il tuo colore degli occhi allora
il mio colore degli occhi è un po
particolare perché come tutti gli occhi
chiari cambia in base alla brucia rumore
lo sofferma strano ma cambiano spesso
però potrebbe essere una sorta di verde
il colore degli occhi dell'altra persona
agli occhi marroni non neri ma marco
figli anita degli occhi bellissimi sono
celesti e cambiano cambiano colore in
base anche alla luce quindi possono
possono girare sul verde però sono
maturi da piccolo con cosa giocavo lì a
giocare con le parli con i lego e da
piccolo giocavo tanto con i lego mi
piacevano tantissimo
queste costruzioni enormi e spesso da
capo con mio fratello lui e lui aveva
più fantasia di me costruiva queste
questi motoscafi elicotteri e giocavamo
insieme a giocare spesso con lui e farmi
aiutare da lui perché lui il più grande
e da piccolo che cartoni guardali tutti
praticamente quelli che mi ricorda di
più ritorno in pokémon sicuramente il
film son e sailor moon non mi ricordo
che mi piacevano tantissimo le miu miu
miu toni che portava da piccolo era
molto mazzarri che è debito willy il
coyote è il tuo pokémon preferito
5 retta ciò che so che sto pikachu quale
è sbagliata se non li distingue la tua
sailor preferita da piccola mi piaceva
tantissimo se lo denuncia ma ora mi
identifico un po di più
conosco non conoscono animali comprare o
adottare assolutamente adottare i canili
sono pieni e se non si adottano a questi
animali non hanno una speranza di poter
vivere in decisamente adottate i canili
e gattili sono che ne avete la
possibilità adottate so che ognuno ha
una situazione differente
però se potete adottate beh
assolutamente adottare già non ha senso
contabili slime preferito il flat batte
slime quello che mi piace di più ai dei
tatuaggi
no nessuno no non è sul tatuaggio ma ho
diverse cicatrici una qui una sul chiede
e l'altra sul ginocchio viaggio insieme
più bello il viaggio insieme più bello
sicuramente è stato quello negli stati
uniti sono stati a new york e in florida
il viaggio più bello sicuramente è stato
quello negli stati uniti di qualche anno
fa dove io anita siamo andati insieme a
motta d'orlando a fort lauderdale vicino
miami chi cucina meglio di lui
decisamente
io cucino meglio numero di scarpe 37 e
mezzo 41 le volte 42 numero di scarpe
dell'altra persona anche regalato delle
scarpe 37 37
ti stai divertendo a fare questa
intervista chi malissimo anche meglio
un'altra moto cosa ti infastidisce
dell'altra persona
il fatto che mangia troppo aiuti
controlla allora cosa mi infastidisce di
anita quanto lei e testarda ma così
testarda che non vuole assolutamente
sentire ragione cosa adori invece
dell'altra persona
e dato che faccia a cannes perché ha
molte tenere una gentile faccia che fa
quando le dico che ha ragione in quelle
situazioni che descrivevo prima in cui
le false per testarda è infatti io mi
sbagliavo le ragione continua a
perdonargli però quindi dovrei cercare
di ascoltarla di più chi è il più
ordinato io lei forse più ordinata di me
ma io nel mio casi non riesco a
ritrovare tutto
chi è il più socievole lui
io più romantico
io nel lazio è il più simpatico ancora
il sindaco che tenta è il più ambizioso
healthcare viziosa io e carismatico io
siamo 30 il più generoso invece è tra i
due per salita se tu sei una cosa di
mano e chi è il più bello penso io però
salutate la stori spam
adesso ciao story spagnoli spero tanto
che questo video vi sia piaciuto
[Musica]